if you'll notice my slugs are bold and
underlined
can you explain why screenwriters should
not use bold slug lines
no
i think screenwriters should use bold
slug lines
bold slugs is one of those things
i know i've talked about formatting
uh bolt slugs is one of those formatting
things that really really really rile
people up especially on social media
especially like on twitter
we get into these formatting wars
uh what's acceptable should you bold
your slugs or should you underline them
or should you
i i don't know it's it's just all sorts
of like craziness
bold slugs i don't think are a big deal
i like to use them
uh i just think that it makes the page
look better
you know separates you know clearly
separates
different scenes
aesthetically you know i just it's
pleasing to me
but if you know you choose not to bold
your slugs or underline them then then
that's fine like that's not a big deal
that's not a big deal
i think
and this is to go back to something i
said earlier i think a lot of the
formatting
wars
uh stem from people
wanting to do their own thing instead of
adhering to
like an established format
people
get the advice all the time you know um
don't make your descriptions you know
your action lines
too long we don't want paragraphs and
paragraphs
of description that's not that's not how
it's done
but someone will
say uh pull a page from
the chinatown script
and say but look at this
this is chinatown you know oscar-winning
script and classic film and you know
there's paragraphs of of you know action
in my mind i'm like well number one it
was written in the 70s i'm sure robert
town wrote that like 72-73
because the film came out in 74.
number two it's robert town
robert town can do that
um
and also
times have changed you know whereas that
was the norm and if you you know look at
scripts from like the 70s yeah you'll
see that they're very like prose heavy
and you know whatever but that's that's
what was done now white space is
you know considered
like that's the good thing you know they
have like a lot of white space on the
page so keep your description short
you know your paragraphs maybe two to
three lines like whatever i mean and
these are all guidelines but
but the thing is you can't hold up
an oscar-winning script from the 70s and
say i want to do it this way because you
know i saw this
now you know
so i think a lot of like the formatting
discussions stem from stuff like that
people see what established writers are
doing
and feel that they can do the same thing
and everyone everyone says you know
because it's all about the story and
that's very true story is the most
important thing
but
kind of goes back to what i said earlier
if
your work
looks sloppy or if it
if it doesn't look like in my opinion
you know if it doesn't look like it's
adhering to
you know proper format no one's going to
get to the story
they're going to look at the script and
say what is going on here
you know this is not a screenplay why do
you think there's more white space on
the page
than nowadays i think
more white space just means less words
uh people
don't have the time to like really sit
down and read like they want to they
want to get through a script as fast as
possible
and so
if there's a lot of white space
i feel that that indicates that
you're telling the story you know
using you know economy of words
and and and they can get through the
script even if you know 100 page script
they can get through it in no time
uh like i think a great example is um
misha green she wrote a script called
mother
uh it's an action script
and
like her
action lines are very short like i mean
some action lines like one or two words
you know and that's it and the dialogue
is also short so there's lots of white
space when you you know flip through it
i can imagine any like
development exec or
producer like getting that script and
flipping through it and being like oh
yeah i can i can get through this and
still have enough time to make it to
fridays for cocktails and potato skins
you know so i think i think really think
that that's why
just people want to read and
get through it as quickly as possible
so then when does the heavy dialogue
come in or it doesn't we're using less
dialogue now
you know i've heard from so many people
you know you don't want to have a lot of
dialogue you don't want chunky blocks of
dialogue you can get away with that if
you're tarantino but
most of us aren't tarantino you know so
they say it's best to keep your your
dialogue you know
short
um
so
yeah i don't know
so the prose heavy woody allen diane
keaton conversations though those as as
wonderful as those are
we're not having as much of those now
right i don't think so i don't think so
and yeah you know like i love those
movies and i love those type those sorts
of exchanges in film you know
uh i think because i
i think i tend to write a lot of
dialogue so what i do
is i break the blocks up using like
parentheticals or using short action
lines this way it doesn't look like
a big massive you know speech a big
massive block of dialogue
and um
giving white space you know separating
these elements but
also giving white space so
i'm hoping that it's it's it's pleasing
to you know whomever whoever reads it
why do screenwriters argue over format
because it's it's it's the one thing we
can control
in this in this crazy industry
is how
our work looks you know how
how it looks when we present it to
someone
and
i just think that everyone feels that
the way they do things is perhaps the
right way to do it you know
i'm an advocate of
proper screenplay format follow you know
like i use a program you know
it works well
uh there's um a book called at least
called the hollywood standard
which also you know has a lot of tips as
far as formatting i think it's a great
kind of formatting guide
i you know i follow that as well if i'm
unsure about something i always refer to
the hollywood standards just like oh
okay this is how i you know because i
want
any manager or producer or actor or
anyone who picks up my script to look at
it and say yes you know just just by
looking at it like yes this is
this is professional work
and then they can read it and get into
the story you know whatever
um
we are in control of that
after after we write the script
we send it out that's it it's out of our
control
and um
and so i think that that's
that's a major
reason is you know
this is us
this is what we can do you want to put
that out there and also
you don't want to give anyone a reason
to
pass
to reject your work
and uh
you know i think that
if you if you give them a screenplay
that that isn't that doesn't look right
i think that that that will happen
right i remember going to like this this
ridiculous resume thing that i was
supposed to go to and the guy's like
yeah you want to use these fun fonts and
you want to make your thing really stand
out and i thought
why because that's going to just confuse
the reader
and it sounds like that's the same thing
like i don't want to submit a script
that has a fourth of an inch margin all
the way around and a cursive font that's
a cool you know gaelic looking thing
right
and you know that's the thing is that
i'm
with formatting you know i'm not talking
about like there are people who uh who
argue over using a fun font on the title
page i think that that's fine i've done
it you know that's cool but the title
page it's supposed to look a certain way
you know you have your title you have
your writer's name and then you've got
the information you know in the bottom
left corner
i think that a fun font you know for the
title is fine but as you mentioned can't
be that fun font throughout the entire
script
like that's that's not going to work
and so
jay you've brought some examples of your
own work here a script
can you talk us through how it should
look
i mean sure i mean
for instance
talking about like
a fun font on the title page like this
is uh
this is my script potter's field oh nice
and i use the font that is supposed to
mimic like
dripping blood
so it's it's a hard but it's a horror
comedy so you know i wanted to get a
little cheeky so give you that horror
vibe but also a little playful little
fun vibe so that's why i did that
okay so you did use a cool font for the
for the title page right right
and i think maybe
a page like this
illustrates what i was talking about
right white on the page right you know
short dialogue blocks
uh the action lines aren't too long
probably like the longest action line
like it hits like three lines here
so i mean yeah and if you'll notice my
slugs are bold and underlined
okay just because again i like the way
that that looks and
breaks up the scene
one thing i'm seeing jay is
your script here is reading more like a
book
and it's less so single page
single page right i mean and this is
just for me like i printed this out you
know like this for me
effort to save paper and you know uh
but no definitely like if i were to
print out a script and send it you know
send it out to someone definitely it
would just you know single side printing
gotcha okay well i'm all about saving
paper
laser printer you know
all the toner things like that okay
great so that's an environmentally
friendly
script right there exactly yeah
and then are the pages numbered
the pages are numbered okay where do you
have the uh you don't number the first
page but you certainly
begin with number two on the second page
okay and you're going to have it up
there
yeah
yeah upper right corner
and then toward the end at the at the
end of the script how does it end
just
kind of like fade out there's no i used
fade to black fade to black i use fade
to black and then
i hit him with an actual v end okay uh
stephen king once again the uh the the
sweetest phrase that that writers
whatever type is like the end he says
something like that uh so i always do
that and that's you know that is another
thing though people people are really
they feel strongly about fade in fade
out
fade to black and i think that those are
all stylistic touches uh you know i like
to fade to black so
okay and the end is it written in all
caps or that doesn't matter i don't
think that it matters but i you know in
all caps and bold and underlined like
the slugs